y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 el que
hacemos un resumen de las noticias
relacionadas con la pandemia del cob y
19 en nuestro continente a continuación
les presento algunos de los temas que
vamos a trazar en este programa vamos a
hablar en la consulta con nuestro doctor
vamos a conversar de la super inmunidad
un nuevo término que ha surgido y que
está siendo estudiado por los médicos y
también por los científicos son todos
aquellos que se contagiaron de kobe 19
los superaron generaron anticuerpos y
además se han vacunado generando una
hiper inmunidad así como esa fecha
tentativa que ha dado a conocer la o ms
para el supuesto fin de la pandemia
vamos a ver qué tan cierto puede ser y
también hablaremos en esta edición sobre
la vacunación que va a iniciar cuba para
los menores de 2 a 10 años veremos el
panorama general de la situación en el
salvador un país en donde está avanzando
la vacunación y los casos de contagio
también allí los ciudadanos
protagonizaron una serie de
manifestaciones contra el presidente de
nayim bukele en donde no respetaron el
distanciamiento social y algunos ni
siquiera llevaba máscara también
hablaremos de chile un país que ya está
listo para abrir las fronteras para los
extranjeros eso sí que estén vacunados
completamente chile está registrando una
de las tasas de positividad y de
contagio más bajas desde el inicio de la
emergencia sanitaria vamos a dar un
vistazo a las cifras de ese país a ver
cómo está y en nueva york' sube el telón
para dar paso a todo el esplendor de
broadway regresa a la industria del
teatro y de los musicales a la gran
manzana con una robusta temporada de
espectáculos y con sus mejores y más
conocidos títulos porque el show debe
continuar pero eso sí con estrictas
medidas de salubridad vamos a comenzar y
si les parece lo hacemos entonces con
cifras veamos cómo ha avanzado la
pandemia de kobe 19 durante esta semana
en el continente americano vamos a ver
alguna actualización de los números
relacionados con casos y fallecidos en
algunos países de la región vamos a
comenzar si les parece por guatemala en
donde allí están haciendo frente a un
fuerte pico de contagio las cifras de
contagio ya superan los 500 21.000
mientras que la de los fallecidos ya
supera los 12 mil 900 a dominicana en el
caribe los casos superan los 354.000 y
los fallecidos ya se contabilizan por
más de 4000 en honduras cierran esta
semana con las siguientes cifras más de
356 mil casos 9 mil 400 fallecidos ya un
poco más de esta cifra y en costa rica
la cifra de contagiados allí superan los
500 mil las víctimas mortales ya superan
las 5 mil 900 ya están por llegar a los
6000 y vamos a cerrar con guyana en
américa del sur que presenta más de 28
mil casos los fallecidos apenas superan
los 700
vamos ahora a la consulta con el doctor
javier nieto él es médico pediatra
infectólogo él se encuentra en la ciudad
de panamá doctor bienvenido gracias por
acompañarnos en esta oportunidad en kobe
19 la semana en américa y abrimos esta
consulta hablando de la super inmunidad
que son estas personas que ya recibieron
las dos dosis de la vacuna ya sea de
facer o de moderna en estos casos ya
cursaron también la enfermedad y han
desarrollado una super cantidad de
anticuerpos según los estudios
científicos que dicen
bueno sí de hecho
había todo este este debate y aquellas
personas que habían estado expuestas a
kobe si era necesario no vacunar y de
hecho la recomendación era que aquellas
personas que habían tenido como
recibirán al menos una dosis de la
vacuna pero de hecho también hay hay
datos interesantes que aquellas personas
expuestas a kobe que ha recibido las dos
dosis responden mejor que aquellas
personas expuestas que han recibido una
dosis y esto tal vez cobra importancia
en el contexto de la emergencia de
variantes
como son por ejemplo la variante delta
que se requiere pues un título de
anticuerpos neutralizantes alto para
tratar de neutralizar esta variante
entonces sabes este es un nuevo look una
es una enfermedad que evoluciona todos
los días y es muy probable que aquellas
personas que hayan estado expuestas a
kobe pues se recomiende completar la
pauta de vacunación con las dos dosis es
la recomendación para todos los doctores
nieto pasó a preguntarle por éste que
hizo la oms que ha dicho que cómo está
evolucionando la situación de la
vacunación siempre y cuando se logre
inmunizar en los países donde hay una
baja cobertura de vacunas para marzo del
2022 estaríamos finalizando la pandemia
del cob y 19 usted no ve posible que
análisis hacia usted
me parece que es un argumento debatible
y te explico por qué en primer lugar
porque hay emergencia de variantes
y por supuesto esta está estas variantes
pueden de alguna u otra forma
poner afectar un poco la efectividad de
estas vacunas como sabes antes de la
circulación de la de la variante de
delta teníamos la variante
británica y después empezó a emerger la
variante sudafricana y ahora tenemos
esta está esta variante del está
preguntando menos sensible en la
vacunación hay que hay que trabajar
también en promover la vacunación
particularmente en aquellas personas que
son escépticas a recibirlas y es
importante también considerar la
vacunación en pediatría o en los niños
porque porque los niños tienen menos
riesgo de desarrollar enfermedades
graves pero pueden convertirse en
transmisores de la de la enfermedad
entonces yo lo siento un tanto un tanto
debatible es importante seguir
utilizándola la mascarilla y a mí me
parece
realmente siendo muy muy realista que
nosotros podríamos enfrentarnos
realmente a una inmunidad de rebaño
colectiva para más o menos en el año
2024 o 2025 si doctor también se abre la
puerta para un tratamiento contra el
jove 19 distinto a las vacunas que
tenemos en este momento y las otras
vacunas que están todavía en desarrollo
y es porque investigadores de la
universidad goethe
identificaron una diversidad de
moléculas que son muy pequeñas y estas
partículas tienen la particularidad de
unirse a algunas áreas del genoma del
virus del cob y 19 y en la mayoría de
los casos no alteran no producen
mutaciones de que lo que estamos
hablando exactamente de qué se trataría
esto
bueno yo creo que es importante en
primer lugar hacer estudios de
eficacia a través de ensayos clínicos
controlados para no solo evaluar la
eficacia sino la la seguridad
de estos productos no es el principal
inconveniente que ha habido con el uso
de los anticuerpos monoclonales que son
parte de los de los tratamientos
administrados de forma temprana en
personas con lakovic es que estos
medicamentos desarrollan rápidamente
resistencia a la emergencia de esta
nueva variante entonces evidentemente en
tener un fármaco que logra mitigar esa
esa posibilidad sin duda alguna es
esperanzador pero vuelvo y repito es
importante tener en consideración los
resultados de los ensayos clínicos
controlados para evaluar la real
eficacia y el perfil de seguridad de
estos productos doctor nietos
rápidamente para cerrar seguimos en este
debate en esta espiral de debate en
torno a si se aprueba o no la vacunación
de refuerzo para
toda la población o solamente para un
sector es decir para las personas
mayores de 65 años o personas que tengan
algunas enfermedades previas la
administración de alimentos y drogas en
los eeuu hace unas horas aprobó el uso
del refuerzo para poblaciones
específicas personas de más de 65 años o
personas que podrían desarrollar
enfermedad severa como son los
trabajadores de la salud de hecho no se
recomendó el refuerzo en aquellas
personas de más de 16 años ahora me
aparece que diluir los refuerzos en el
contexto de que a nivel global sólo se
ha alcanzado vacunar a un
35 por ciento de la población con al
menos una dosis y alrededor de 2 por
ciento de la población en los países en
vías de desarrollo con la pauta una
dosis me pregunto si realmente este es
el gran momento para que nos
circunscribimos a ese debate si es o no
necesario un refuerzo a mí me parece que
hay que de circunscribirse a vacunar a
la población global con la pauta de los
dos gigantes de diluirlo en este debate
del refuerzo doctor nieto desde ciudad
de panamá muchas gracias por habernos
acompañado aquí en kobe 19 la semana en
américa de haber aclarado estas dudas
para nuestros televidentes muchísimas
gracias pues ya lo mencionaba yo en el
avance de los temas cuba va a comenzar a
vacunar a los niños de 2 a 10 años de
edad eso sí lo va a hacer con las
vacunas locales recordemos que cuba es
el primer país de américa latina que ha
desarrollado sus propias vacunas contra
el kobe 19 veamos
no parece gustarle pero lucía de dos
años de edad le permite a cuba
convertirse en la primera nación en
vacunar a niños tan pequeños contra el
cob y 19 con el objetivo de inmunizar a
más del 90% de los cubanos antes de
diciembre todos los niños de entre 2 y
10 años recibirán dos dosis de la
soberana dos y una de la soberana plus
tal como se hizo con los adultos también
saltó mucho y me dio preocupación al
inicio realmente pero bueno con el
comando ya tanto con los redes sociales
por la visión
[Música]
además de las soberanas producidas por
el instituto finlay uva desarrolló otra
vacuna nacional abdalá ambas fueron
aprobadas por los organismos reguladores
locales para su uso de emergencia pero
todavía no son reconocidas por la güemes
y como nosotros desarrollamos nuestra
vacuna pensando en el niño porque es a
lo que se dedica el instituto fin
levadura lo desarrollamos sobre la base
de plataformas de vacunas infantiles y
por lo tanto nos fue mucho más fácil
avanzar en población e infantil que con
el resto las vacunas que son vacunas
nuevas con las cuales hay temor incluso
de que pueda pasar con la población
infantil las escuelas del país llevan
cerradas desde marzo de 2020 y el
gobierno cubano decidió que no reabrirán
hasta que todos los niños del país hayan
sido vacunados
y no me da miedo nada de las autoridades
sanitarias locales indicaron que la
circulación de la barba en fidel está
produjo estas semanas un aumento de las
infecciones en toda la isla afectando
dicen especialmente a los más pequeños
veamos ahora cómo avanza la vacunación
en américa latina' para el cierre de
esta semana les presento el porcentaje
de personas que han recibido el esquema
de vacunación completo vamos a comenzar
en panamá
allí las cifras ya alcanza el 48 punto
26 por ciento de la población con la
vacunación completa república dominicana
en el caribe cierra esta semana con el
43 punto 74 por ciento de la población
totalmente vacunada barazil el gigante
suramericano cierra esta semana con el
35 punto 86 por ciento de la población
seguimos nuestro recorrido con mexico
allí la cifra llega al 31 punto 47% de
la población con el esquema completo
terminamos en paraguay donde las cifras
llega al 25 punto 38 por ciento de la
población
y nos vamos ahora hasta chile porque
poco a poco la vida cultural en ese país
va recuperándose después de 17 meses de
cierre el teatro nacional de santiago
reabrió sus puertas al público esta
semana con un aforo limitado a un tercio
de la capacidad que tiene normalmente
para volver a mostrar todo su esplendor
la ópera carmen fue la pieza escogida
para esta reapertura veamos
llegó la fecha tan esperada para el
mundo de la cultura en chile tras una
pausa de 17 meses el teatro municipal de
santiago el principal del país se
reencuentra con su público en esta
ocasión su principal bailarina andrew
sarandí shake se despide del público
después de 24 años de carrera en el
ballet chileno
estaré apertura es posible debido a
retroceso de la pandemia conseguido en
parte gracias a una campaña de
vacunación exitosa que comenzó de forma
masiva al 3 de febrero de este año
actualmente 13 de un total de 19
millones de chilenos tienen el esquema
de inmunización completo de hecho el
país encabeza la lista de naciones que
más vacunaron en la región allí el 70%
de la población ha sido ya inoculada el
martes el gobierno empezó a vacunar
adolescentes y niños inclusive hoy día
comenzaremos y retomaremos la vacunación
de los adolescentes de 14 a 17 años que
no lo han hecho hasta este momento pero
también comenzaremos hoy con los niños
los niños de 6 a 11 años pero no solo
los aficionados de la danza se
benefician de relajamiento de las
medidas anti cobit aunque con una
capacidad de reducida y el uso
obligatorio de la mascarilla los
estadios salas de conciertos y quienes
ya abrieron sus puertas dando la
bienvenida a una parcial normalidad
ya lo veían ustedes chile es uno de los
líderes en la vacunación en américa
latina' y tal parece que la media está
comenzando las medidas se están
comenzando a dar frutos vamos a dar un
vistazo entonces a las cifras para ver
cómo está la situación en ese país
austral en chile ya los casos que han
contabilizado llegan a los 688 mil los
fallecidos alcanzan los 19 mil 100
mientras que la vacunación alcanza la
impresionante cifra del 72 punto 82 por
ciento es líder en la región es la cifra
para el cierre de esta semana
continuamos en el sur del continente ya
lo decíamos que chile junto con uruguay
son los líderes de la vacunación pero
también hubo importantes anuncios a lo
largo de esta semana como por ejemplo la
apertura de las fronteras y la
tranquilidad de saber que la tasa de
positividad no supera ni siquiera el 1%
vamos entonces hasta santiago allá se
encuentra nuestra corresponsal patricia
luna hola patrizia gracias por estar con
nosotros y el gobierno ya autorizó
entonces la apertura de las fronteras
del país para el ingreso de los
extranjeros pero con vacunación completa
que como son las medidas
hola santiago los extranjeros que
quieran entrar a chile ya podrán hacerlo
por primera vez en varios meses a partir
del 1 de octubre y lo podrán hacer a
través de tres puertos de entrada al
país el aeropuerto de santiago que ha
estado abierto a extranjeros con
anterioridad durante la pandemia pero
por primera vez durante este periodo de
la pandemia estarán abiertos también los
aeropuertos de antofagasta e iquique en
el norte del país los extranjeros que
quieran llegar al chile deberán de
cumplir una serie de requisitos bastante
estrictos entre ellos estar vacunado
homologar ese sistema de inoculación con
el sistema chileno a través de una
página web en un trámite que puede
demorar hasta un mes presentar también
una declaración jurada un pcr negativo
con no más de 72 horas de antigüedad y
un seguro de salud que cubra hasta 30
mil dólares además de eso se verán
obligados a guardar cinco días de
aislamiento forzoso con estas medidas el
gobierno pretende reactivar la muy
deprimida industria del turismo chileno
que ha sufrido mucho y muy duramente las
consecuencias de la pandemia
patricia se llama mucho la atención de
esta semana la cifra destacada y es la
positividad de chile por kobe 19 que no
supera el 1 por ciento que dicen ayer
las autoridades al respecto
tiene vive un momento de bastante
tranquilidad en cuanto a las cifras se
han registrado algunas de las cifras más
bajas desde el inicio de la pandemia en
las últimas semanas con 300 400 500
casos diarios y una positividad que
normalmente se ha situado por debajo del
1 por ciento a nivel nacional sin
embargo este viernes se registraban una
tasa de positividad levemente superior
de un 10 3% lo que desataba un poco las
alarmas porque llevan cuatro días
consecutivos en que se ha registrado un
mayor número de casos que los mismos
días de la previa semana el ministro de
salud de enrique en parís realizaba unas
declaraciones a la prensa para mostrar
su preocupación en un momento en que el
país se prepara para celebrar sus
fiestas más grandes las fiestas patrias
que no se celebrarán en este año como lo
hubieran hecho antes de la pandemia pero
sí que habrá un mayor número de
actividades que hubo en el año pasado en
el plena encierro durante la pandemia
esto junto al hecho de que se han
registrado más de 1000 casos de la
variante del está identificados al menos
1000 el 60 por ciento de ellos de
transmisión comunitaria revirtiendo la
tendencia que se veían en las últimas
semanas en la que la mayoría de estos
casos se registraban en los aeropuertos
hace que las autoridades muestren su
preocupación por este leve incremento en
el número de casos que se reportan a
diario
patricia muchas gracias por este
completo reporte desde la ciudad de
santiago la capital de chile vamos a
seguir en suramérica esta semana también
entró en vigor el uso del pase sanitario
en la ciudad de río de janeiro en brasil
el documento es obligatorio para
ingresar a recintos deportivos también
para asistir a eventos o visitar
monumentos que representativos de esa
ciudad que mueve muchísimo turismo tal
parece que tanto los turistas como los
residentes han recibido de muy buena
manera esta medida recordemos que esta
semana también brasil remontó en cifras
de contagios fallecidos 800 muertos
registraron en solamente 24 horas veamos
los hinchas regresaron al mítico estadio
de maracaná pero para asistir al partido
de cuartos de final de la copa brasileña
los más de 20.000 espectadores debieron
dar santo y seña un certificado de
vacunación o de recuperación del cobi 19
este pase sanitario no frena el
entusiasmo de los aficionados de los
clubes flamengo y gremio que se
enfrentaron ese día
un año y medio es mucho tiempo cuando
estás acostumbrado a venir al estadio
con frecuencia si otros clubes aplican
las mismas medidas sanitarias que el
flamengo creo que todo el mundo acabará
volviendo
después de una interminable pausa
estamos de vuelta la última vez que vine
al estadio fue en febrero de 2020 por
fin podemos volver siguiendo las
restricciones sanitarias muchos
aficionados al fútbol fueron víctimas de
kobe 19 pero gracias a dios' ganaremos
el nuevo pase sanitario se aplica a los
locales turísticos y culturales de río
pero no a los bares y restaurantes en
una ciudad que se vio duramente golpeada
por el cob y 19 con más de 30.000
muertes desde el inicio de la pandemia
esta restricción es bastante bien
aceptada
[Música]
creo que exigir un certificado de
vacunación es una forma de controlar el
número de personas vacunadas y cuantas
más personas se vacunen más protegidos
estaremos y también protegeremos a los
que nos rodean
con casi 580 mil muertes brasil es el
segundo país del mundo después de eeuu
que más ha sufrido la pandemia de kobe
eeuu está haciendo frente a una
desacelerada tasa de vacunación pero eso
sí a un incremento constante de casos
hospitalizaciones y fallecidos demos un
vistazo a las cifras con las que termina
esta semana eeuu para el cierre de esta
semana entonces la unión americana
reporta más de 41 millones 800 mil casos
los fallecidos ya superan los 670 mil
mientras que la ocupación de las salas
de cuidado intensivo en las últimas dos
semanas han llegado al 74 punto 77 por
ciento la vacunación completa llega
solamente el 53 punto 57 por ciento de
la población en eeuu la variante
dominante es delta que representa el 100
por ciento de los casos reportados en
los últimos 28 días
el estado de florida sigue teniendo una
situación crítica el jueves de esta
semana este estado reportó 50.000 de
personas fallecidas por kobe 19 en medio
de una guerra política por el uso del
tapabocas en las escuelas públicas y
también por supuesto la baja vacunación
vamos a ir entonces hasta miami ella se
encuentra ante nivel sin nuestro
corresponsal permanente en el sur de la
florida para conocer más detalles
antonio buenas tardes allí en el sur del
estado de florida y comenzó ese debate y
esa polarización en torno al uso de la
mascarilla en las escuelas públicas
usarlas o no usarlas que es lo que dicen
al respecto
pues sí hola santiago el debate sobre el
uso de mascarillas se ha acentuado en
algunos estados como florida o tejas
aquí en el estado del sol la polémica
llegó después de que el gobernador
republicano ron de santis firmara una
orden ejecutiva que prohibía
expresamente los mandatos del cubrebocas
en las escuelas el gobernador decía que
ésta tenía que ser una decisión de los
padres y que ningún gobierno podría
hacer este tipo de imposiciones a pesar
de todo varias juntas escolares
desafiaron esta orden y obligaron a los
niños y adolescentes a ponerse las
mascarillas en los centros educativos la
medida incluso ha llegado a los
tribunales especialmente porque se
quiere que sea la corte estatal la que
acabe decidiendo si esa provisión de ron
de santis es ilegal o no de momento la
pelota se va moviendo de un tejado a
otro un juez ha dicho que el gobernador
no tenía potestad para ello mientras
otros sí que lo ha respaldado otros
estados
están haciendo lo mismo como en texas
pero ahí finalmente se ha llegado a un
consenso y los legisladores están
trabajando en una normativa específica
para que las juntas escolares puedan
poner sus propias leyes sobre el uso de
mascarillas
antonio hablemos de las cifras ya lo
decía 50 mil fallecidos en sólo 24 horas
el jueves de esta semana es el estado
con el más alto número de muertes
acumuladas en los últimos 28 días
si con esa cifra de 50.000 muertos por
coronavirus se confirma que la pandemia
está lejos de llegar a su final en
florida el estado ocupa el undécimo
lugar de la peor tasa de mortalidad por
cápita de todo el país y lo más
preocupante es que ha escalado seis
posiciones en tan sólo dos semanas el
gobernador a pesar de que ha reconocido
de que este último año y medio ha sido
especialmente complicado se ha opuesto a
la imposición de vacunas como hemos
dicho antes también al uso de
mascarillas y de hecho floridas se ha
convertido en una especie de oasis en
medio de la pandemia básicamente porque
aquí no se ha impuesto ninguna
restricción en los comercios podían
operar completamente sin ninguna
restricción los turistas también venían
aquí en busca de fiesta y desenfreno y
los médicos han dicho que ese ha sido el
factor principal para que pues este
estado pues viera una irrupción de casos
positivos de coronavirus también se está
viendo un aumento de casos entre los
jóvenes ha también acentuado con la
aparición de la variante delta que es
mucho más contagiosa antonio pues
complicado el panorama en el estado de
florida muchas gracias por este reporte
desde la ciudad de miami vemos ahora un
vistazo a las cifras de el salvador este
país centroamericano allí al igual que
sus vecinos conmemoraron el bicentenario
de su independencia y así está avanzando
la pandemia kobe 19 en este país los
casos allí superan los 99 mil 700 se
aproximan ya a los 99 mil 700 perdón y
se aproxima ya a los 100 mil los
fallecidos acaban de superar los 3.000
pero el 48 punto 95 por ciento de la
población tiene el esquema completo de
vacunación
precisamente en el marco de la
conmemoración del bicentenario de la
independencia del salvador fue una fecha
también elegida por los ciudadanos para
salir a protestar contra el gobierno del
presidente nadie bukele en unas
protestas en donde hubo aglomeraciones
falta de distanciamiento y algunas
personas no usaron mascarilla
vamos a conocer cómo está la situación
allí con la demil chamorro desde la
ciudad de san salvador hola vladímir
gracias por estar con nosotros hoy y en
el marco de estas marchas de lo decíamos
mala organización aglomeraciones no
usaron mascarillas y muchas personas en
la capital salvadoreña
hola efectivamente el salvador vivió el
pasado 15 de septiembre el bicentenario
de la independencia centroamericana con
protestas en sus calles en lo que se
considera la mayor manifestación contra
el presidente bucl en poco más de dos
años de su mandato miles de personas
protestaron en la capital en rechazo a
las medidas tomadas por el gobierno
entre ellas la adopción del bitcoin como
moneda oficial y la posibilidad de que
buque le pueda reelegirse en el 2024 al
igual que otro tipo de actividades las
manifestaciones ocurren pese a que
existe un decreto tan transitorio que
prohíbe este tipo de concentraciones sin
embargo el presidente no reaccionó al
incumplimiento de esta restricción pues
fue evidente que no se respetó el
distanciamiento social y había algunas
personas que no utilizaban correctamente
la mascarilla por el contrario en su
discurso a la nación reprendió a la
comunidad internacional acusándoles de
financiar las protestas
vladimir hablemos de la vacunación y de
las restricciones que siguen vigentes
allí
respecto a ese tema te comento que
recientemente el presidente buque le
destacó que el salvador posee el mejor
ritmo de vacunación en la región
centroamericana el gobierno salvadoreño
ha recibido cerca de 12 millones de
dosis de vacunas contra la cob y 19 con
las que se ha cubierto con dosis
completas
aproximadamente 3 millones de personas
mayores de 18 años otro aspecto
destacado es que ya se habilitó la
vacunación para niños entre 6 y 11 años
según autoridades de salud el promedio
de contagios diarios ronda los 330
también han confirmado que hay
circulación de mutaciones del virus
entre ellas la variante delta aunque no
se ha dado a conocer qué porcentaje de
pacientes se han contagiado con esta
variante de momento el salvador se
acerca a la frontera de los 100 mil
casos confirmados de coronavirus y
supera los 3.000 fallecidos por esta
enfermedad la de muchas gracias por este
completo reporte desde la ciudad de san
salvador y les cuento brevemente otras
noticias destacadas a lo largo de esta
semana panamá ofrecerá vacunas de
astrazéneca a los turistas que lleguen a
ese país la idea es atraer a personas
que busquen la aplicación de dosis y
también permanecer unos días en panamá
de esta manera esperan reactivar el
sector turístico panameño y perú amplió
el estado de emergencia nacional hasta
el 31 de octubre dicha medida fue
instaurada el pasado mes de marzo y su
extensión tiene lugar cuando la
tendencia en la curva de contagio de
kobe 19 es a la baja pero es tomada de
manera preventiva para una eventual
tercera ola que podría causar la
variante delta en ese país suramericano
y vamos a finalizar en guatemala en
donde fue aprobada una ley de emergencia
por la atención de la pandemia de kobe
19 18 meses después de haber empezado la
emergencia este decreto fue aprobado
incluye la vacunación para menores entre
los 12 y 17 años también por estudios de
referencia para los medicamentos y bonos
de pagos extra al personal de salud así
como incentivos para los estudiantes de
medicina que ya están atendiendo a
pacientes con kobe 19 como parte de sus
rotaciones hospital
y nos vamos ahora a colombia país que
esta semana recibió más de 3 millones de
dosis de vacunas contra el jove 19 a
través del programa de ayuda kóvacs y
también gracias a una donación del reino
de españa el país también registró las
cifras de contagio más bajas desde el
inicio de la pandemia y no reportó
víctimas mortales en las últimas 24
horas también dio inicio a la
inoculación de la tercera dosis para las
personas mayores de 70 años 38 millones
de dosis de vacunas ya han sido
aplicadas mientras que se espera un
cuarto pico para finales del mes de
octubre
es un pequeño alivio para una gran lucha
en colombia en plena escasez de vacunas
anti kobe y entre quejas por la
anulación de citas para segunda dosis el
país sudamericano recibió este lunes más
de 3 millones de vacunas gracias al
programa kóvacs un tercio fue donado por
españa en una alocución junto con el
ministro consejero de la embajada de
españa el presidente colombiano iván
duque aprovecho para agradecer al país
ibérico valoramos esta donación que está
haciendo el reino de españa a nuestro
país de 1 millón 100 mil vacunas
aproximadamente de las cuales estamos
recibiendo hoy
957.000 a través de la plataforma cobats
el presidente también afirmó que para el
cierre de 2021 se espera tener al menos
35 millones de personas vacunadas con la
segunda dosis es decir el 70 por ciento
de la población colombiana el primero de
julio en el momento más crítico del
tercer pico los eeuu ya habían enviado
más 2 millones de vacunas a colombia
estamos aquí para ayudar a colombia al
alcanzar la inmunidad de rebaño con un
mínimo de 70 por ciento de su población
recibiendo al menos una dosis de vacuna
para septiembre al 13 de septiembre se
registraban más de 1300 nuevos casos y
40 fallecimientos las cifras más bajas
registradas desde que colombia logró
salir de su prolongado y letal tercer
pico que en sus peores momentos llegó a
cobrarse la vida de más de 600 personas
por día por el momento alrededor de 15
millones de personas están al día en su
vacunación a nivel nacional pero según
el propio gobierno esta sería una cifra
insuficiente para detener una cuarta ola
de contagios que podría llegar en las
últimas semanas de octubre
y ahora demos un vistazo a otras
noticias relacionadas con el hobby 19
que también fueron destacadas en redes
vamos con esta publicación chilama con
no de manera completa a más de mil
millones de personas por mil millones
estamos hablando del 70 por ciento de la
población de china sus armas han sido
las vacunas sinovac y scinopharm
desarrolladas localmente y miren también
que lo que está sucediendo todo lo
contrario a lo que sucede en cuba el
organismo internacional de la opc afirma
que los menores se contagian y hasta
pueden morir por kobe 19 pero los
riesgos se incrementarán con la edad y
por eso sigue sin recomendar que sean
vacunados esto va contrario a lo que
están diciendo las autoridades de la
isla de cuba
y después de 18 meses de cierre la
industria de broadway en nueva york que
emplea a cerca de 150 mil personas va a
subir el telón para poner en marcha una
esperada temporada musicales como 'el
rey león' chicago aladino y moulin rouge
ya están disponibles para locales y
también para los turistas pero eso sí
con medidas de bioseguridad
18 meses después de su cierre causado
por la llegada del cob y 19 los teatros
de broadway se preparan para la
reapertura de sus puertas al público un
momento especial y emotivo para los
actores que se sienten aún un poco
oxidados por no subirse durante tanto
tiempo al escenario
extraño va a estar frente a una
audiencia y en su momento me parece que
fue lo justo sabes quiero decir todo era
tan aterrador durante la pandemia y era
una especie de sensación de alguna vez
la vida volverá a la normalidad
los gnomos
el musical conforme way cuenta la
historia sobre un pueblo canadiense
pequeño que recibió siete mil pasajeros
varados después de que su avión fuera
desviado a raíz de los ataques del 11 de
septiembre
una historia apropiada de solidaridad y
compasión 20 años después de los eventos
traumáticos que sacudieron el país y la
ciudad hasta los huesos
el momento es perfecto el aniversario
número 20 del 11 de septiembre y la
reapertura de broadway específicamente a
nuestro espectáculo que habla del 11 de
septiembre y de la comunidad miraría los
teatros comenzaron su apertura a
mediados de abril en nueva york pero
broadway permaneció cerrado ya que los
teatros esperaban que las restricciones
sobre la capacidad se levantaran con la
mayoría de los principales musicales
incluyendo a hamilton y el rey león' que
retomarán la próxima semana los artistas
están ansiosos por estar de nuevo bajo
los focos del escenario
porque el show debe continuar pero
nosotros llegamos hasta acá los
esperamos la próxima semana con más
noticias relacionadas con la pandemia de
kobe 19 sigan cuidándose nos vemos aquí
en france 24
[Música]